we are in the same room but we look
different we turn the table around yeah
we change it up a little bit this week
welcome back everyone to the Jenna and
Julian dress ah ah we're sharing a mic
relationshipgoals
I know we're trying something different
we're trying something different why not
why not uh if it sucks let us know but
hopefully it won't suck it might suck
might suck this week's episode of the
Jenna and Julian podcast brought to you
by Squarespace
Squarespace is one of the easiest and
cleanest ways to create your own website
whatever website blog online store you
want to create
Squarespace calm has all the templates
has the ease of use customer service
check it out at squarespace.com you
don't need a credit card to sign up for
your free trial we'll talk more about
that later and thank you Squarespace for
supporting us Thank You Squarespace um
anyway yeah so we we decided this week
you're gonna do the podcast against kind
of a plain wall with our our sound
boards up here sound wall because at the
sound wall yeah
well cuz we've been putting a lot of
effort into getting new lenses and
getting the camera right and getting the
lighting right and we felt like with all
the colors and stuff behind us it was
getting kind of wasted like all of the
efforts that we made with the new lens
and making things look crisp it was all
getting washed out not that the art
didn't fit our background because we
love it but we're still gonna keep it
no it's still right there it's we're in
the same room it's just we're gonna try
to try it out and like I said this might
this might suck you know I mean this who
cares like we'll try it out and so I'm
in trying yeah um
Bernie I think I think it's I think it's
the podcast is also sponsored by the
fact that you're sweating everywhere are
you HOT are you okay do you need some
water
I just like work dolly an hour a walk
and then I just never really kind of
calmed down Julian's gonna do jillion
things true things variously come in
here and set up the podcast me and my
Aires self move furniture every sorry
I'm not sorry but I'm sorry I'm sweating
it's okay we like your sweat and also
this podcast brought to you by me not
chewing gum yes
kill me last week I didn't even notice
honestly that you were chewing gum while
I was sitting here otherwise I would
have said something to you
yeah well the fact that you didn't I
don't argue but he'll gum the internet
was angel yeah
anyway we got back from Arizona
yesterday and we want to apologize that
the podcast didn't get up yesterday we
literally had no time it was just
absolutely not so I fell asleep
we fell asleep we were just completely
exhausted I had a show in Arizona and we
drove home yesterday so um that's why it
wasn't obviously and we're really sorry
we won't let it happen like that again
we're sorry sometimes life just kicks
you in the dick right in there and bring
the dick around a tip yeah and then when
you lose bent over it kicks you in the
balls and you're like [ __ ] it is the tip
or the balls where's the ball balls at
it just like stings sting like if
someone kicks you in the tip of the dick
you like wow wow but if you're in the
boss say oh okay my day is over yeah
yeah got it good to know holding on to
that he learns something new every day
the more you know rainbow team I rate my
name is on my shirt but I promise I'm
not an [ __ ] someone made this for me
it says youtube.com slash [ __ ] you Dale
so I'm wearing it so I guess we we
decided would be fun to talk about
Caitlyn Jenner yeah because that's been
huge in the news and she made her I
guess reveal like to date yesterday or
two days ago yesterday okay Monday bail
yeah call me Caitlyn came out and she
had the photo shoot pictures her eyes on
what was it Vanity Fair yeah pretty cool
um I just I think ok so there's so much
to talk about when it comes to this
topic first of all when we watch the
Bruce Jenner interview with Diane Sawyer
that was interesting but it was also
like you know what I didn't like for me
and I think a lot of people who may not
know too much about the genders in the
Kardashians to watch that interview it
was like okay well you know they have an
interesting story and they just want
to use whatever platform that Bruce at
the time when it had earned to be
himself be himself or herself now and it
was a little frustrating watching the
interview I think for more than it was
so [ __ ] frustrating because obviously
I'll speak for myself
obviously Diane Sawyer needs to speak on
behalf of a lot of people that don't
understand what transgender means or why
that's a thing or what the [ __ ] is
happening she's speaking to a lot of old
Bible Belt people and things like that
but just like so we're playing we're
drinking but we're playing a drinking
game like drink every time Diane Sawyer
says some really ignorant [ __ ] like
questions that you would never ask or
need to add yeah like I forget what you
saying is it's been a while now but
things just like um you know so like are
you really a woman nor like whoa what
would you what do you what do you do
well just saying I don't understand and
they seemed insensitive I think more
than anything like she was asking
questions that were not only kind of
offensive and ignorant but they were
like beside the point
like like Bruce was trying to convey
something right and she was just picking
apart these like things that she's not
like normalized to like these things
that she's not used to or that maybe the
people she's representing as like the
ignorant people of America don't know
what it is and she was just like picking
these things and like asking weird
questions instead of just being like
okay well let's talk about you now well
talking about your decision yeah you're
now moving on with your life and it's
better yeah instead of maybe letting him
explain more I mean I imagine he did a
fair amount of explanation in their
interview but what they aired or her
stupid questions like why now like why
did you wait so long because you missed
all the fun of being a girl and he's
like I know I mean I totally blacks you
to the top of a sleigh I did we like to
thug like that at tweet of that um when
that happened cuz basically she was just
like being a dick and she said like you
know you're all basically like you're
all now why would you become a
when you're old and and then he was like
oh I know now we have to look forward to
and then he just point out everything
she was wearing it was amazing yeah and
she was sort of backhanded about the
fact that gender and sexuality are
different you know and that that for
some reason was like groundbreaking news
and she's like oh so you so you don't
want to sleep with me so you're not so
you're not gay well what would we call
you like it's all you know that's what
it really became all about these like
labels that she was trying to put on yes
how can I fit you into a box and it was
frustrating how can I put you in a box
like I'm fit into a box every day when I
go to work right [ __ ] that that so that
was I mean like I said it was it was
more there was more than one emotion
going on in me like why I watch that
because I was like very like it was cool
and I was like you know I don't know who
Bruce Jenner is before that well like we
had talked about and Jenna knows
whatever but I was like that's like
proud of them
you know I was like proud of Bruce for
doing that and at the same time I was
like what the [ __ ] man the world is
watching this and they get to just like
sit and watch you just kind of
disrespect this whole issue yeah
what I think a lot of people were
frustrated yeah with that yeah um it got
a little Diane Sawyer II she got her
Diane Sawyer all over the place but yeah
I mean Bruce Jenner was a very famous
person and has been a very famous person
for a long time like my you know our
parents generation know exactly is
because of he's such a famous Olympian
and I mean the pressure of him feeling
that internal struggle and taking this
long to decide that he fully wants to
transition is no surprise because like
what the [ __ ] man yeah what the actual
[ __ ] yeah why wouldn't it take him that
long yeah absolutely I mean the fact
that he's able to do it at all I know
I'm lying it's it's horrifying the
entire world knows you as this macho
Olympian and for you to like have these
urges that you just feel like you cannot
show the world because they see you as
this how I mean think of that like like
I know it's hard to relate to this type
of thing if you if you're not in the
same situation or wherever or you're not
aware of what it what it is but just
that alone it's like you have created
this I mean amazingly positive like
macho
accomplished athlete persona and then
you want to completely turn into
something else which you should be able
to do but I understand completely why it
took forever and why it's going to be
like a hundred hmm I honestly think that
it was a great time just in our culture
because people [ __ ] starting to get
it do you know what it means like there
they stopped treating the transgender
community as this confusing sort of like
drag community yeah they're starting to
take it more and more seriously because
people are now being surrounded by
family members friends neighbors anyone
that you know people in the pop culture
are supported going through this that
like hey guys this isn't a joke this is
like the gender I feel that I should
have been assigned at birth and you know
I I want to make my physical appearance
and I want to live life as a woman or a
man but what I think is important is
that I've seen a lot of posts online
about this but that people have been you
know congratulating Caitlyn and that
she's so beautiful which year she is
let's not get that - yeah Caitlyn is
[ __ ] fierce but that many people that
are going through like the transition
into becoming a man or a woman do not
have endless funds to get all the
surgeries that maybe they would want not
even close and so that it's important
that we don't focus on Caitlyn's
physical attributes that we focus on
congratulating the bravery and the
honesty that it takes to become the
person that you want to be on the other
that's a very important thing to make as
a point-like
you know it's great that you know
Caitlyn is now becoming this face of the
transgender community in mainstream or
whatever you want to call it and it's
great that she's beautiful and she got
all the surgeries you could ever want to
become a beautiful woman but yes
it is so expensive to do what well
because it's easier for our culture to
look at someone that has had you know
they have breasts they don't maybe have
an Adam's apple they have laser
surgeries who don't have hair but
there's a lot of people in the world
that can't afford that and so that when
people the majority rate we
we see someone that we're not quite sure
what gender they are because they can't
get all of those surgeries it's just
kind of outrageous for an average person
drop hundreds of thousands of dollars on
surgery yeah so it's not about us
Jimmy it's not about people that are
looking in on that person and oh does
this make sense to me it's about that
person's transition and what they
identify as and that we are rewarding
people that are taking brave steps to
make this a thing that's more we get it
you need to make stupid-ass [ __ ]
ignorant people get it absolutely okay
and you know what I think anyone does
look [ __ ] fierce yes like it slay
another thing though I really like I
don't know and I really just think that
like there's so many people out there
who look at something like this like a
transgender woman who's very famous as a
man and makes the transition and you
look at the process and you look at the
new product and you look at everything
around it and it's all very new like
it's confusing it's new you don't really
know what like how to say certain things
to not be effect like you don't I mean
like you're not ignorant but you're also
just not very not like you know you
don't know you don't know too much about
the issue so I think it's important to
draw the line between not really
understanding and being new to it and
being ignorant about it like I think
there's a lot of ways that those two can
kind of mesh and I think and I think I
identify with someone who you know at
you know recently in my life you know
I've got I've gotten more and more
knowledged and you know understanding of
the issue because I've you know I've
learned and met people and all this
stuff but I think like it I identify
with someone who maybe looks at
something like this sounds like well I
don't I just don't understand like how
it works or I don't understand what to
say or how like it that's okay you know
what I mean that is an okay thing that's
just that's someone who just needs to
make time to understand and learn the
right right and that's the difference
between maybe not knowing and being
ignorant because a person that's
ignorant
just [ __ ] says whatever they want
yeah a person that doesn't know
it's okay to ask questions yes you have
the joke a neighbor or a family friend I
mean don't ask offensive questions you
don't need to ask about their genitals
or maybe there are people that are fine
with that but I mean be sensitive ask
questions maybe that you wouldn't want
to answer don't ask those questions it's
not all about like feeding your
curiosity but ask questions certainly if
there's someone in your life that you
know like hey would you like me to call
you this or this or things like that
it's okay to not know the answer and
also if you're just a person that's
uninformed there's no harm or shame in
going online and reading as much as you
can a little research that you don't
have to feel confused because it's not a
confusing thing yeah it's honestly kind
of just a whatever makes you happy and
is your doing I love and support you and
respect you and that's all that matters
yeah and I think that the the people who
are against it or the people who are
mean to people who have this transition
and stuff like that I think they let
this confusion consume them to the point
where they're frustrated and they want
to take it out so they're like mad at it
not knowing what it really means or why
they're mad you know I mean they just
let that confusion take over instead of
just like fixing and learning and
becoming a little more educated on
what's like well oftentimes those people
that are so angry and frustrated are
people that end up having family members
or people close to them that are in the
LGBT community or you know whatever
they're transgender they're anything and
they find themselves at a crossroads
because they find themselves in these
situations like I love you but this
doesn't happen to me like the you know
the gays and that ever those are there
in San Francisco they're in New York
like it doesn't happen yeah yeah I can't
be I doesn't happen to me and then they
have to figure it out and I like all
those stories that you see on the news
and [ __ ] where it's like these a whole
like just [ __ ] [ __ ] people and
they're like I hated gay people until I
realized that my son was gay and now I
love gay people yeah and it's it's silly
and it's ridiculous but I hope that you
know by someone so famous and has-been
in the public eye for so many years by
his bravery he's at least going to help
other people chase after the fact that
they don't want to hide anymore they
don't want to feel different they don't
want to feel sad on the inside they want
to you know live their [ __ ] truth in
their life and that the stupid ignorant
people around them will be forced to
make a change in their mindset because
our country at least the youth of our
country is sick and tired of this being
an issue and we cannot wait to live in a
world where this is a non-issue because
it's not an issue to us no it's not yes
should it ever be right but you're right
the youth of America is absolutely tired
of that of it I agree that's a good
stopping point really quick a little bit
about Squarespace our sponsor this week
Squarespace com is uh is it's really one
of the best ways you can build a website
a blog online store anything that you as
a you know personal project want to
create or professionally if you need
something to be hosted on a web site and
you want to look clean but you don't
know how to do that
Squarespace Tarkan has all the tools to
make it look just how you want to make
it look clean there's tons of templates
really nice looking templates to choose
from
they work perfectly on mobile platforms
it's not like a desktop website
everywhere I see you can't use it on
your phone which everyone's on their
phone now so that's a huge thing it
comes with a free store any website
comes with a free online store built in
your website and the 24/7 customer
support
should you even have a question not that
you know it's likely because it's very
easy to set up
they're there for you 24 hours a day
seven days a week on chat to help you
solve all your problems
Squarespace com seamless create a
website and people will think you're an
absolute genius for it like I said you
don't need a credit card to sign up or
start a free trial you can just start it
but if you decide you want to get
Squarespace you can get 10% off your
website with product code jayjay at
checkout you just enter jayjay when
you're checking out of your website and
10% off let us know if you guys try it
out how you like it but Squarespace comp
thank you for sponsoring that's crazy
not even like
bank or phone company is 24/7 customers
and the thing about starting a free
trial with no credit card I mean nobody
does that they're always like yeah it's
free but give me your give me your money
though anyway yeah so you know that to
what you were saying the the feeling of
being inside the wrong body or the
feeling that you wake up every day and
just it's eating you alive of like the
fact that you or not you and you want so
badly to express who you are I think
that's the most important thing that
Caitlyn has done is expressed what that
felt like right and made a change
because of it and I think there's so
many people I know there's so many
people out there obviously who feel that
way and now maybe have a little bit more
courage to pursue being themselves or
whatever they want I just I honestly
think that it's great that someone from
our parents generation I don't like my
mom your mom like people like that I
don't give a [ __ ] ever then they're not
the people that you need to be spoken to
but because it's Bruce Jenner and that
was a very famous person in our parents
generations lives for a lot of the older
people that don't understand the people
that are making the laws the people that
are in charge of what flies and what
doesn't in terms of government laws and
legislation whatever to see someone that
they may be idolized for a long time
come forward and just explain just say
what it feels like like I think that
that might help some of these old people
that are stuck in their ways that refuse
to understand yeah because they're
clutching their Bible and you don't know
what yes and you know that's absolutely
true you know it's like they think of
that and that's where I think Diane
Sawyer really did a disservice because
yes you're speaking to an older
generation because most of us that are
under maybe 30 or so are so affected by
the gay and transgender community
because at this point we all know
someone it's these are right it's more
accepted than it's ever been worse
emerge and we watch their struggles like
you'll go to the mall and you know
you've had friends in the past or
anything and you're gay transgender or
whatever people
have a hard time getting a job in the
past or just like being treated like a
regular [ __ ] citizen yeah you hear
the things that are said to them on a
daily basis yeah or just it's like it
hurts us as much as it hurts them
because you love them Jimmy maybe our
parents aren't like once you're 50 or 60
you don't really meet as many new people
maybe as you did when you were a younger
person so it doesn't affect you unless
it's a child or a niece or a nephew or
something like that
yeah and then it hits close to home
absolutely I think that Diane did a
disservice by not addressing the fact
that so many people loved Bruce and it's
important that you hear his story and
now Caitlyn's story because these are
the people that need to [ __ ] get it
and wake up Jonah me absolutely and
honestly I didn't even like put it
together like that because the way you
just laid out is is really great the
fact that our parents people who watch
Bruce grow up you know be this Olympian
identify as one of Bruce Bruce is their
generation Reedy's bad and so it's like
this does like make a huge it's like yes
GG gorgeous is incredible and she's done
a major service for people of our
generation
right but exactly like the people who
are so not in with this LGBT and the
transgender community the older people
are around now are like well now you
know Caitlyn was one of us Caitlyn is
one of us we are someone who has to
identify by the law of math we were
growing up when when Bruce was bruising
now Caitlyn you know I mean it's like
they are directly associated to whether
they like it or not and they and that's
something that what Caitlyn has done is
like problem you know maybe not Caitlyn
did what she had to do for herself but
maybe by a product of that like kind of
force people the older people to be like
you know what I'm also your age and look
what the [ __ ] I'm doing get with it yeah
stop denying that this is an issue stop
denying that it's a really really good
point right um I also long before I
found Gigi gorgeous and YouTube and all
that and I was
you need to get her on the podcast um I
was in a class I don't remember the name
of it but we had a woman who
transitioned into a man like years ago
and was full like it's a man I can't
member his name honestly but he came
with his girlfriend yeah that was there
with him through the whole process and
he basically said to us you know he
talked to us about it he did whatever
and this was before I knew or even
whatever that she could go online and
maybe see some people making videos and
talking about it I didn't know that this
was probably my first chance to sit
there and raise a hand and ask questions
and you know this guy hit my boys name
damn it but he was basically like ask me
anything that you want this is for
purposes of Education or in the trust
tree in the nest so there's no judgment
like and there's no such thing as a
stupid question just get it all out and
I think there was maybe only one
question about the physicality of it the
rest of it was just yeah the rest of it
honestly like reach me yeah Wow
she's just about you know he was a
student no he was a little bit older
okay so it's not good but we most of the
questions revolved around like his
family and friends and getting a job and
like what the transition was like yeah
um I think only one question asked one
question was about what the actual likes
is a character yeah okay um which is
impressive and great to hear I love
hearing that kind of thing when people
well yeah because obviously we don't
really care that much Jimmy like I don't
really care how many surgeries you had
or what you did we asked about the
hormone medication and know it like
especially from female to male because
it does like your your voice box like to
thank your vocal cord stretch out like
your voice does get lower yeah you do
start to grow hair and deals like that
so we have some questions about that but
we don't really [ __ ] give a [ __ ] you
know
no about the rest of your body because I
don't really care just like I don't
really care who you [ __ ] in your free
time I really don't give a [ __ ]
I mean that's that's honestly like it's
like he wouldn't ask just the straight
person me like oh like how's your dick
or like what is your dick look like
Danny like it's it's
like so not your business right um but
after after that uh I basically we all
stood up we like it was standing
ovations there's only like 20 people in
this but we we were like I wish that
class was six [ __ ] hours long and I
remember I walked up to him I shook his
hand and I was like thank you so much
for this and I will gladly pay back all
of my school loans after just this one
[ __ ] conversation they know this was
that important to me to be able to sit
there and just you know have an
opportunity to ask questions yeah and
then all of a sudden who the [ __ ] cares
anymore
I mean honestly impressive that they
just did that and I real-life AMA I feel
like that often times is what GG is
doing for the Internet absolutely but on
a way bigger platform
I mean exactly no it's just an
opportunity to have one or two questions
or thoughts like you know how how did
how did it work with your family and
everything like that now just one
question in your mind to have it make
sense to you like all of a sudden I have
no like diffic difficult time
understanding or caring yeah I don't
really care but from there on out just
from one positive experience you're then
able to apply that in a sense to anyone
that is anywhere on a spectrum of
anything and you're like you know what
man I think I get how this feels not
really I get that's a terrible design I
want to say that all because I don't I
don't get how it feels but I think I
have an understanding of what's going on
and we're trying to say and I don't have
any questions and just love you and
that's the type of understanding that
you gained that you can't get from like
googling and look at 18 year old yeah
you're just like oh I don't I don't have
any more questions yeah high five I mean
but seriously though like that's amazing
that you went up and said thank you to
him afterwards I feel like a lot of us
in that situation would have felt the
same way it's just it's it's like thank
you thank you so remember you know I
mean it's just a powerful experience
yeah it's someone being it it gives you
like a I'm trying to be careful with the
way that I'm saying this yeah coming out
wrong
no but like to just have it hit home to
you and like in a personal way you're
then better equipped because it's not
something that I'm going through
joining me I'm better equipped to
understand how important it is to use
the correct like he or she or buy the
purse which is important it's a small
thing but how important it is to you
know I don't know just a lot of things
it just helps you a lot when you know
someone or you've met someone and they
just teach you or tell you just a couple
of things no strings attached they just
want to help you learn right and then
anyone else that's on any spectrum of
the transitioning you're just like it
doesn't matter to me I care about you
and I will call you whatever you want to
be called and I respect whatever you're
doing and do you good for you
for real though but it does take a I
think I'm hoping that Caitlin did that
for people where it's like okay I get it
now yeah and I don't I don't need to
have any more question yes yeah and and
you know also in addition to that
hopefully Kate Caitlin instilled in the
people who want to have you know that
transition that it's okay to do it and
then just be open and help people learn
you know like Caitlyn's doing it's just
like it's uncomfortable maybe but it's
it's so important to know that like that
is what like your experience with that
that guy in the classroom and I mean it
means everything will be honest like
Bruce Jenner was privileged and that he
was an incredible athlete he made a
comfortable salary you know and it's not
always as easy not that I could call
anyone's transition easy but it's not
always as easy for people like clearly
his family has supported him they care
about him yeah and you know he has money
to do whatever he wants with it Cheers
right there's many people in the world
that don't have any of that their family
is not accepting whatsoever they can't
afford certain things that they would
like in order to feel more like
themselves yeah and I think it's
important that we remember that it's not
all about the physicality of it and it's
not all about
I don't know yeah no it's very important
and I think you know as much as
it's great that Kaitlyn got all the
surgery and looks beautiful and got
people's attention by doing that you
know photo shoot and everything it's
great like you know to do that and to be
the example like that but it is very
very important when people understand
that that's not at that everyday
situation people don't do that every day
that they transition it's just it's just
not realistic right but I think it's a
big step
absolutely I mean and rock Obama like
tweeted about it and said you know it
takes a lot of courage I mean it's it's
it's a new age and it's hopefully
getting even better and better with
something like this with people
understanding this community and what it
means and you know everything around it
right [ __ ] amen yeah Caitlyn Jenner
Kaelin slab a Caitlyn Jenner it's really
cool man Caitlyn probably used the
square space so Caitlyn's people have
like websites for her I just like I
think it's so [ __ ] awesome though that
like you know Bruce had to go through so
much in terms of paparazzi taking
pictures of him and just writing these
someone's our Harper my under eater I
hope everyone that used those pictures
to sell covers of magazines and [ __ ]
they had such an opportunity and they
continue to have an opportunity to
portray this in a positive light and
they were choosing to ski zhilie sell
magazines being like Bruce's transition
la la la and not even that just like
what it like calling Bruce like a thing
or like being completely [ __ ]
ignorant right weird pictures it wasn't
respectful it was slander E and awful
and I hope that they use it as a
positive tool instead of this negative
Slammy SEL magnetic man you know it's a
little it's a takes a little more
courage to do the right thing in terms
of like being the media in this
situation it's easy to be [ __ ] pop
right I mean I watched a video I think
it was like on that special or something
you showed me a work Bruce was like
literally just walking to his car from
coffee and realized like he couldn't go
get coffee because you know there were
people everywhere and he like wanna just
go to coffee but he had to go back to
his car send his car and get [ __ ]
asked ya by these [ __ ] with cameras
and I was just like oh my god that's a
human [ __ ] being like what are you
doing it's just heartbreaking but you're
right
like no hopefully in that sense his
transition is much harder well hopefully
any people
no absolutely that's absolutely right
and that's why you know all the
surgeries that he's getting and he
deserves it you know she deserves it in
a way so but anyway I hope you guys
enjoyed this conversation obviously it's
a heavy one it's not some like easy
conversation but it's one that I feel
like we really wanted to have and
especially yeah now with Caitlyn coming
forward and with her new look it's
awesome and she looks beautiful know as
much as we shouldn't focus on someone's
beauty she I think I think the internet
really said that though and we most
people's first reaction is to be like oh
my god Caitlyn you look beautiful and
we're not trying to focus on just that
she's a beautiful woman it's it's a lot
of inner and outer beauty mixed together
that interview just bravery is what's
getting loved Bruce in that interview I
was like God the brute likes bravery and
like just not giving a [ __ ] and just
being straight up like we enjoy I like
you I know you and Brett enjoy that
interview but really not like that were
like it was like emotional and like I
had never been super exposed to Bruce as
a personality like I knew his Olympic
background stuff like that but I never
watched the show so I I was like the
first time I got a peek in like him
and now her and I was like wow that was
[ __ ] cool like you handled that [ __ ]
like a boss yeah like a boss but it's
done I imagine that it's very difficult
to get asked ignorant questions and have
the level of patience that he's taking
the high road on every single question
like yeah he did he didn't scoff at any
question that she asked
he wasn't rude he wasn't anything he
sort of just tried his best to explain
it to someone that seemingly had no
knowledge with a smile the whole time
the smile on is smelling no Caitlin's
yes and although I haven't really read
anything about it I think it is
interesting that Caitlyn is held at sea
in that again I love
I love that we can talk more about that
I don't know I just love that I want to
know if you leave in the comments what
those speculations are for the see in
the not care yeah let us know yeah I
like to imagine it's because he's a
Kardashian 2.0 like just [ __ ] all you
guys my Zach uh sound but with a see
yeah because I'm better oh my god no
yeah seriously though I mean honestly
let us know your your thoughts on
discussion we've had and your thoughts
on the issue and your thoughts on
Caitlyn Jenner because you know and keep
it positive and respectful but you know
it's it's if you don't agree with any of
this we respect your opinion as well and
you're totally entitled to that and have
that as long as you don't be nice ya
know attend this is the I think this
might be one of the videos where we
flagged comments if they're bad so just
you know yeah be nice um thank you guys
so much for hanging out with us and
thank you for accepting our apology even
though hear you say we accept your
apology if you just know you accepted it
for being a day late this week we love
you guys and we'll be back next week
just remember to check out Squarespace
calm and you can click the link in the
in the description right now to go
straight there but also use JJ at
checkout to get 10% off or just start a
free trial no credit card needed build
your website on mobile online store
amazing customer service Squarespace
calm thank you for sponsoring the
podcast Thank You spiritualist
we love you guys we'll see you next week
and we love you Caitlin we love you
Caitlin alright see you guys